Why would somebody with cancer have anemia?
So in anemia, there's different types of anemia.
So you could have anemia due to blood loss.
You can see that in a person with cancer.
If the person has, especially if they have a cancer
in the intestinal tract and they're having bleeding,
then they have blood loss.
Or you have a vaginal cancer, a uterine cancer,
where you have blood loss.
You could have anemia due to a loss of blood.
So let's say a person doesn't have cancer
and they go in for a regular physical
and they have low red blood cell comb
to some other signs of anemia,
the red cell width and things like that.
The first thing that doctors should do
is try to investigate what is the cause of this anemia.
But if a person already has a diagnosis of cancer
and now their hemoglobin is going down
to their red blood cell count is going down.
Their red cell width is going up things like that.
Other signs of anemia of chronic disease,
that's a different type of anemia.
So anemia of chronic disease is actually the name
of a type of anemia that's very often,
very common in cancer,
especially later stage cancer,
it's common for a couple of reasons.
Number one, if the person is doing chemotherapy,
chemotherapy can affect red blood cell production
and cause anemia of chronic disease.
If the person is not doing chemotherapy,
another reason why you can get anemia of chronic disease
with cancer is because of a general state of inflammation.
Inflammation, especially that affects red blood cell
production is not uncommon and that can be a cause.
Another cause can be the cancer is godly up iron.
Iron can be a fuel source for cancer
that can be one of the issues.
And that is kind of a, becomes problematic
because typically if a person has iron deficiency
in anemia, what has to do with blood loss,
you'd give the person iron
and you can't give the person,
or you have to be careful giving a cancer patient iron
because it can be feeding the cancer.
So that's why you would always use that iron
or an revisited protocol if you're going to do that.
So you'd add an revisited with the iron
if you do want to supplement iron.
Another side note of this, if a person has elevated ferritid,
even if they have anemia, you can't give them iron.
So if you have elevated ferritid and you give iron,
you're going to make the person worse.
Elevated ferritid is a side of heavy inflammation
and you have to be careful with that.
So there's multiple reasons why you'd get anemia with cancer.
You have to investigate all of those.
We've had questions on this forum in the past,
multiple times whether a person should get a blood transfusion
if they have anemia.
That's quite severe and the answer has been,
well, typically they will give you one every hospital,
every clinic has their cutoff range.
Usually you have to have a hemoglobin below 8.0.
Some of it, some people, some clinics, it's below 7.5.
Some it's you have to be down to 7.0 before
they'll give you a transfusion.
And my answer is always, yes, I think it's in the best interest
to get that, it can really help you feel better.